you
[Music]
all right welcome to the afternoon
session we have two speakers now both
talks are 20 minutes the first one
session gauranga
with annotation artifacts and natural
language inference tape all right
everyone my name is Sachin graduates to
inverse Washington it's gonna be a
project called annotation artifacts and
naturally because inference data I'm
here with Microsoft or so assume that
the this is joint work with Omer levy
Royce Schwartz Sam Boehm and Noah Smith
so who here works with crowd-sourced
annotations or maybe works with data
sets on crowd-sourced annotations yeah
so this is a really popular sort of area
of NLP and it really drives a lot of
modern NLP and so you know we're given
usually given some text we have a model
and we have some output here um it's
hard to figure it's easy to forget that
you know there are humans behind the
text and that data that we feed our
models - and those annotators because
they are human they have their own
biases they have their own beliefs about
the world they have personal motives
they have their own cultural backgrounds
and this affects the distributions that
we see in our data and there have been a
lot of there's been a lot of
conversation about how biases affect
downstream societal applications what a
sort of long-running theme of this talk
is that biases also affect how we
evaluate models and our design of our
tasks so the story sort of starts with
the natural language inference task
which I think a lot of people here are
familiar with basically you're given two
sentences of premise and a hypothesis
and the goal is to determine whether
that premise entails that hypothesis so
there are three categories so for
example you're given on the premises
north wall Northwest MLP workshop is
being held with Microsoft headquarters
you have an entailment category the
workshop is in Redmond because that's
definitely true giving this premise a
contradiction that Amazon is hosting the
workshop because that can't be true and
a neutral example that sucked in Adela
is attending the workshop not know if
he's here but see these are relatively
well defined classes and it's really apt
for annotation we've had a lot of really
great performance on this task over the
past few years the Stanford nli and
multi no idea sets were released in past
couple years
and people have been getting scores in
the 70s and 80s across these two
datasets and so a newcomer to this
particular area of NLP might see these
scores and be like okay there's not
really much else to do and I know why
like what am I doing here but I think
the results of this paper kind of show
that there is a lot to do most
nli models especially the top performing
ones sort of represent both the premise
and the hypothesis and some sort of
joint way feed that a joint
representation down to a classifier to
predict those three labels what we found
very interestingly is that if you
completely disregard the premise and
only consider the hypothesis only feed
the hypothesis into that classifier and
make the same prediction so you can do
really well on this task the model the
classifier that we use in this
particular experiment was fast text
which is not the self text
categorization model from Facebook
models those words as diagrams you know
grams very very simple we were able to
get 67 percent accuracy on ethanol I and
about 55 percent accuracy and multi-and
all I and this is kind of harrowing this
tells us that those days that's aren't
really doing what they're supposed to be
doing we don't really need to learn
entailment to perform about 2x above our
majority baselines and so the sort of
project that we embarked on was really
to answer this question of why we're
able to do so well on this task with
just the hypothesis we showed that
elicited annotations induce lexical
clues which we call annotation artifacts
that reveal the entailment class we
showed that supervised models especially
the top performing ones exploit these
annotation artifacts to make their
predictions and we present the water
implications for model evaluation and
task design and so hope even though this
talk is very centered around the sort of
nly data hopefully anyone who's working
with creating datasets using
crowd-sourced annotators or evaluating
models in general can benefit from these
develop results so the first argument we
had in our paper was that there exists I
aren't Asian artifacts and analogic
policies that heavily correlate with the
entailment class and I'm not going to
walk through how we how we how we showed
that but I think it's prudent to think
about how these datasets are generated
in the first place so essentially SLI
and multi
are generated through sort of captions
own source text from multiple genres
that are fed to annotators on MTurk who
are then asked to create those three
hypotheses entailment contradiction in
neutral there's a real focus on scale
here both from the annotators
perspective as well as a test designer's
perspective the test designer wants as
many examples as possible so we could
feed those you know data hungry neural
nets and annotators want to maximize the
reward annotate as many examples as
possible and sm align multiple i achieve
about 1 million high agreeing examples
and this is really great for that this
particular area of NLP because previous
datasets either relied on expert
annotators or relied on very specific
theories of entailment that we're very
hard to scale in this paper under this
framework we showed that annotators are
sort of trying to maximize their
efficiency in creating these hypotheses
and thus introducing these sort of
heuristics and tricks to create examples
that our models have trained on and so
I'm gonna go walk through some of the
artifacts that we found in the paper we
quantitatively justify them in the paper
and there are a lot more artifacts that
we show in the paper so if you're
interested definitely check them out
so entailment artifacts included
generalizations we saw a lot of premises
that are entailment hypotheses that were
associated with premises like some men
and boys are playing frisbee in a grassy
area and tailmon having generalizations
over entities in that text people
playing frisbee outdoors we also see
shortening where specific words are
removed from the premise for example
here the word shirt and the word green
are removed to just create the
entailment hypothesis neutral artifacts
contain purpose clauses for example if
two dogs are running through field the
neutral fossils that was created was
some puppies are running to catch a
stick basically an ambiguous situation
was created by applying a reason to the
premise modifiers were also really
popular where people just stuck sort of
adjectives or superlatives and fronted
entities in the text and the premise to
sort of create the neutral hypothesis
and contradictions have very very
consistent trends negation was really
Beeler this is one of my favorite
examples because the premise is very
intricate and like complicated has a lot
of stuff going on but the contradiction
that they chose was nobody has a cat
which is like really really simple and
it's a it's a valid form of entailment
but it's something that models could
really really easily pick up on cats
were also really popular in the
contradictions the flicker 30 dataset
which is what the SLI data was derived
from contains a lot of dogs and so
people thought cats were country to dogs
I sort of disagree with that having a
cat and a dog but this is sort of the
human belief and the sort of biases that
get imbued into the data set based on
people's previous experience so we've
shown that artifacts exist and the next
argument of the paper is that supervised
models the top performing ones exploit
them to make their predictions and the
way that we showed this is we revisited
the original model that motivated all
this work that hypothesis only
classifiers we were able to do really
well on Espanola with and multi no mind
with we basically fed in the test data
for both Multi multi online SLI and if
the hypothesis only classifier was able
to get that example right by just using
the hypothesis we consider that example
easy and if it was if wasn't able to do
this so we consider it hard and so in
this way we partition the test data into
hard and easy subsets and we also
revisited the models that I originally
showed that did really well on SNL I'm
multi no line we basically tested these
models on the easy and hard subsets and
see it out and saw how they did we
basically showed that easy examples
drove an alive performance if you see a
graph here this is the accuracy of the
same models on the full data we got
about 87 percent accuracy if you look at
just the hard examples the ones that
hypothesis only classifier was not able
to get correct the accuracy of those
models drops pretty significantly 10 to
20 points and if you look at the easy
examples those models are do do really
really well so this kind of shows us the
majority of the examples of these models
ever to get right are the ones that have
annotation artifacts we get very similar
results in multi and line to check out
the paper you learn more
so given these results I have a few
closing thoughts you can think of
annotation artifacts as sampling bias
it's possible that so I mean it's
crucial to know that like none of these
examples are invalid forms of entailment
right they're all correct they're just
dominating the data set these very easy
lexical heuristics are dominating the
data set so it's possible that like a
good way to solve this problem is to
sort of normalize the distribution of
strategies that are used to create
entailment hypotheses not only using
these lexical heuristics but also using
things like world knowledge or like
political perspective well other forms
of entailment that don't readily exist
in that dataset another really important
thing to realize is that the reason this
is a problem is that a lot of these
models are very lexically driven and
they're very susceptible to these
artifacts you know what we want is a
very general representation of
entailment that is invariant to these
artifacts but what we see is that these
models are making less cool associations
between words and surface patterns like
Yasmin was mentioning to these labels
and so we have to really rethink about
how we're modeling entailment to try to
create representations that are really
invariant to these problems we see also
this is not just about Noi this paper I
think is a child of a series of papers
that have come out recently thinking
about datasets and critiquing how
datasets are either created how models
can be easily broken based on by
introducing adversarial examples and I
think that you know more work like this
should be done I think it's an important
part of doing NLP that we're empirically
driven and that we're sure that what
we're measuring and evaluating our
models for are actually what they're
learning lastly I think progress in
tunnel I has been overestimated I think
that there are a lot of open questions
that sort of result of this work that
really focus on how we do better
annotation how can we direct annotators
to avoid these simple heuristics when
generating examples can we employ some
sort of automated real-time sort of
ward system that disincentivizes using
simple heuristics are there alternatives
to elicitation that help can help us
build sorry
until my data sets I think that there
are ton more open questions and I'd love
to talk to people about it if you're
interested we release the hard
benchmarks on cog ons on Elias if you're
interested in natural ingredients I'd
definitely encourage you to check these
benchmarks out and test your models on
both the full benchmarks as well as
these hard subsets to see if you
generalize across these artifacts and
thanks here's the link to my paper okay
we actually have lots of time for
questions okay thanks so are there
interesting patterns to the Hard
examples or other more diverse yeah so
we didn't include this in the paper
because it's a very hard problem but
when you look at the hard subsets it's
not that they don't contain artifacts
it's that they contain very different
types of skews from the easy subset so
for example maybe you'd have a lot of
examples in the hard subset where like
knots the word knot and Nate and
negation is associated with a different
class like neutrals or entailments and
so it's a it's kind of an open question
about sort of how we utilize hard
quote/unquote hard training data in the
best way is there a way to remove these
artifacts yeah it's hard to tell
I've lost teenagers so what I was
thinking specifically with the example
of negation that seems one that's sort
of like maybe would be like kind of
natural to contradiction you know and
maybe the reason people are like making
those sentences like that is because
that's such a natural way to like
produce contradiction so in that way it
seems kind of like that is like could be
like a natural bias that you wouldn't
want to like remove right yeah I was
wondering like some of them like cat
obviously like that it's like a problem
from the initial like data said it seems
like that right some of them seem less
like yeah yeah hundred percent and I
mean like none of these examples are
invalid forms of entailment like they're
all valid I think the key is when we're
evaluating our models we got to make
sure if we are saying that we're making
a lot of progress on nli like what are
we actually making progress on are we
making progress on these easy lexical
heuristics or are we actually making
progress on like general entailment
right so it's really a question of how
we build our datasets so we're
evaluating our progress on these tasks
and the best way possible
so you define your easy examples as the
one that your basic model was able to
classify correctly but do you make a
difference between the ones that the MAL
the physical examples are actually easy
versus the ones that the model picked up
by chance we don't make that distinction
I think there's there's actually some
work that my co-author so I was about to
work on with like bet cream better
partitions of easy and hard subsets by
using maybe like an adversarial model
that is sort of online trying to
classify both easy and hard examples
while another model is trying to
actually perform entailment and sort of
predictions I think this is really just
a good first step into trying to build a
better easy hard subset but there's
definitely a lot more work to be done to
create those partitions more accurately
so you said this paper was part of kind
of a series of papers I'm just kind of
curious do you know like is there other
research going on into artifacts and
annotations potentially for different
problems but similar data sources yeah
um I personally haven't seen much work
in this area I think that there's
generally been a lot of work on how
there's actually there was actually a
lot of parallel work that had been done
with other groups on the nli data set
showing that not only are there biases
with these sort of heuristics that
people use there's also biases in the
context of like people are introducing
stereotypes into the data you know and I
think those are separate problems I'd
say that this is definitely nascent work
and there needs to be more work done on
this area - okay thanks yeah one else
question
more of a statement than a question one
strategy we've had so we rely on
Mechanical Turk for a lot of language
data one strategy we've had is to
actually get users to filter themselves
out so you get them you ask them
questions that can become wrong or say
like their answers have to be XYZ length
to your negation example for instance
this there might be for the research and
strategies into that I suppose any any
thoughts on that
yeah I think that's I I feel like
nowadays there's a lot of friction and
like trying to create the sort of
real-time interaction between annotators
and like when they're creating is really
huge datasets and a lot of times you're
not able to identify these problems
until after the fact right and then it's
hard it's too costly to go back and like
recreate the data set so I think like
some sort of real-time way to review
things and batches or examples and
batches or something like you propose
would be really influential it's an
expensive problem yeah okay
let's thank the speaker done so Yujin
sort of teased a lot of what I'm gonna
talk about in this talk which is pretty
much neural networks mouths without
brains also you know listeners without
brains sort of goes both ways
and I'm sort of gonna talk about how we
can give them a brain so you know Yujin
talked a lot about recipes and I'm gonna
do so as well I usually love to give
this talk right before lunch because
it's nice to see people squirm but let's
start by having you think about making
an apple pie when you bake a pie there's
the process that you follow in order to
compose your raw ingredients into a
final product intermediate steps such as
slicing apples cooking them placing them
in a pie sheet and then baking the pie
all have to be correctly navigated in
the right order and with the right
intermediate constructs if you're gonna
make something that's you know both
edible
and tasty and understanding that process
requires many common-sense causal
inferences to be made and remembered
later on you know first once we slice
the apples we have to understand some
notion that their shape has changed you
know when we saute them for a bit we now
know that they're cookin Asst has
changed that their temperature has also
likely changed to be warm and also
despite having caused these new changes
we also still have to remember that
they've been cut from before that shape
is still the same we're no longer
dealing we're not we're not going back
to having a raw apple that's had a
completely new set of things done to it
then when we add them to the pie sheet
we have to understand that there's
actually a new entity that's been
created from our sliced and cooked
apples and you know the dough that we've
now combined it combined it with and
finally once we throw it into the oven
we have to know that that combination of
apples and pie sheet is now going to be
cooked so if we think about how you know
current models current intelligent
agents might parse this information you
know current ubiquitous approach using
LST em you know encode all the words
into some type of sentence
representation that's usually a single
vector or a group of vectors and you
just sort of hope that that information
can then be queried from that
representation at a later step you know
that's not necessarily what happens
though you know while L STM's are sort
of powerful representational tools they
don't do much more than encode surfaced
word patterns and they generally haven't
been shown to capture more complex world
dynamics that might be necessary for
reasoning or some other downstream task
that you want some more complex models
you know memory networks or entity
networks do allow for more fine-grained
state representations because they
generally split this encoded context
across memory cells which might allow
you to retain processed information
better or you know encode certain parts
of your context in different ways but
they still don't capture any information
beyond what's explicitly state on the
text you're just learning text patterns
and learning how to represent those in a
particular way so the problem with these
approaches done is that you know the
models we're building aren't ones that
currently learn context representations
that track the state of the world with
all of the VN from
that's needed to perform downstream
tasks most neural state representations
encode only surface patterns between
tokens and they generally devolve into
encoding the most simple pattern that
they can in order to get at the task
that they're trying to do so what might
be a strong enough representation for
some applications might not be good for
another one right after and so the
reasoning that you use in one
application might not be useful for what
happens next in another one so what we
really want ultimately is for the
representations that we learn to
understand some underlying dynamic about
the world and not just a dynamic about
the tasks that we're training it on and
so this is why we decided to approach
text understanding from different
paradigm understanding the state of the
world means understanding that that
world is entity centric and it involves
identifying the state changes that those
entities experience and many of these
state changes however might be
knowledge-based as opposed to text-based
so instead of being explicitly mentioned
in text there might be an expectation of
prior common-sense knowledge that your
model actually needs to know so in this
work more specifically we're going to
address the following challenges we're
going to design a simulator that's
entity aware and that focuses on
capturing information that describes
changes to entities so after reading any
sentence and a recipe we're gonna choose
an entity apply transformation to it and
then we're going to update a running
representation of its state and later we
should be able to predict attributes of
this state based on an embedding that
we're tracking and storing for it and
second we're going to integrate
common-sense knowledge about physical
state changes into the neural network by
adding knowledge about action causality
as a structural bias so we're going to
do this by allowing a predefined set of
action embeddings to cause changes to
our entity States so raw text is
actually only going to be used to select
entities and select actions and the
actual simulation of the events that are
described in the text is going to be
done by applying these learned action
functions to the entity state embeddings
so then the ultimate goal is really to
learn a set of good action functions
that can consistently induce the correct
state changes and entities based on the
text that's being read and we're sort of
gonna do this in a two step process
first in order to develop a neural
architecture that can learn these
effects of actions
that they have on entities we're gonna
crowdsource a set of action state
mappings and then we're gonna see how we
can use this crowd source information to
learn the parameters of a neural network
that is structured to capture the
inductive bias of how actions affect
state changes and entities so the crowd
source set of action state mappings not
particularly interested but we extracted
a set of 380 verbs from the cooking
domain that are mentioned fairly
frequently and then we manually compiled
a set of six state changes that actions
could entail so location composition
cleanliness cook goodness temperature in
shape and by using the state changes of
supervision we can learn the
transformations that act that actions
should induce an entities so for each of
the 384 actions we actually crowdsource
a set of state changes that that action
tends to induce an entities so for an
action like cut we're generally going to
expect to see a change in shape for an
action like boil we're gonna see a
change in cook goodness and in
temperature so you can have multiple
state changes for the same action rinse
involves change in cleanliness and
stirring might involve a change in
composition and so then now that we have
this action state mapping knowledge we
come up with this model which we call
the neural process Network because it it
models the processes that are described
in text which is a new neural network
that decomposes the state tracking task
into one of tracking actions and
entities and learning the
transformations that those actions are
going to induce in the entities and so
to do this the model actually keeps
track of a set of state embeddings for
the entities that it can change
throughout the process and an own set of
action functions that can actually
change those entities and one of which
corresponds to each of the actions that
we crowd-sourced earlier so let me go
over what the model is going to try to
accomplish to a high level in the
interest of time I'm not gonna go into
too many details about it cuz I really
want to get to the results but I'm
actually going to focus in on a couple
parts that I think are super interesting
so the first thing that happens is sort
of typical is that it's going to read in
a sentence using some type of recurrent
neural network such as the GRU and it's
going to build a sentence representation
for it so in this case I'm gonna use
this running exam
with cooking the beef in the pan to
highlight a couple of things using this
encoded representation from the encoder
it's going to select entities that are
going to be changed by the events in the
sentence using an attention mechanism
that sort of computes a binary choice
over each individual entity and this
allows us to choose multiple entities to
be changed in a particular sentence so
in this sentence for cook the beef in
the pan it would choose the beef entity
then the model is going to select an
actions that's going to be that it
thinks is changing the entities that
selected earlier in the sentence by
computing an attention over the action
functions that were initialized at the
start so here it might select the action
like cook it might also select an action
like put because it recognized that pan
is usually associated with a location
change and then inside this applicator
function it's actually going to compute
a by linear projection between this
action embedding and this entity
embedding and come up with a new state
embedding that corresponds that it
thinks is a reflection of how this
entity is selected earlier has been
changed so in essence this is the step
that understands that now some cooking
action has been applied to the beef from
earlier and from that it should actually
be able to tell us what about this
entity has changed using a set of
classifiers once for one for each of the
state change types that we were tracking
earlier so in this case the beef is now
hot it's now cooked now of the pan
meanwhile there hasn't really been a
change in cleanliness at all and finally
it updates this information in the
entity state embeddings so the entity
states reflect the state changes that
the entities have experienced like I
said this involves log neural networks
I'm not gonna go into every single
neuron specifically but here's a couple
things I want to highlight about it
first when the model predicts the state
changes that an entity is experienced
the errors from predicting those state
changes get back propagated back all the
way to the action embeddings in the
action selector which allows us to learn
representations of actions that are more
likely to induce the correct state
changes in the future
second point I want to highlight is that
when we update the entity state
representations in the memory we update
it we update each slot proportional to
what its original attention was when we
selected that entity and what this does
that allows us to model interesting
compositional effects when two entities
are mixed for example so because both
slots might be selected at a hundred
percent we're going to overwrite both of
them with the
same embedding that we got at the output
which allows us to pretty much reflect
that these two things are now the same
entity because they've been combined in
a mixture and the last points the last
thing I want to point out is this idea
of recurrent attention so in its
sentence such as cook the beef in the
pan it's pretty clear which entities
like that should be the beef but if I
all the sudden change that sentence to
cook it in a pan all of a sudden it
could refer to pretty much any entity it
really depends on what has been seen
earlier because you know it's a co
referent Oh
so what we want to do instead is that
we're going to allow the model to attend
to previous attention steps so that it
can select entities that have been
selected prior sort of an attention over
attentions in order to be able to select
entities that were seen before so
there's a lot of details around data
sets and training but I encourage you to
look at the paper for those it's a very
interesting paper I wrote it but what
we've done here is toast what we've sort
of done at a high level is to build a
simulator that captures the dynamics of
actions being taken to the cooking
domain as it reads recipe lines so the
underlying task is really to read a
recipe and be able to predict the
entities that are changed and the state
changes that they undergo in each step
so obviously this leads to a great task
of state change prediction and we use
the accuracy nf1 of predicting the
correct state changes and we weigh them
by the accuracy of predicting the
correct entities and we're better than
competitive neural base lines such as a
GRU which you know kind of we would
expect to be as well as the recurrent
entity Network which is one of the best
models on the babby data sets for
machine comprehension and when we look
at how well we choose entities we see
where this improvement actually comes
from so in the in the right in the
leftmost column we see that we have a
much better f1 score of predicting the
correct entities at every step and this
actually is not necessarily because of
how well we predict raw entities so we
do do a bit better when we look at
recall of predicting the raw ingredients
compared to the two baselines but it
really which is you know raw ingredients
would be something like predicting cut
the tomatoes and then even something
like co-reference or lighted arguments
but the big difference is really how we
do in predicting compose entities
so if you think about something like
combine the water and flour in a bowl at
the next step if you know we have some
like stir the mixture until a dough
forms you know it's really tough to know
that that dough refers to this water and
this flour and we pretty much double
performance that these baselines can
actually manage predicting these types
of compositional entities which is going
to help us do a better job of tracking
the state of entities overall you know
just looking at examples here melt
butter in a medium saucepan over heat in
the first step most models should be
able to predict that the butters being
changed and the second step removed from
heat there's an alighted argument but
we're able to predict that anyway you
know the third third step stirring oats
sugar flour all these fun things you
know we still understand that the
butters is still there it needs to be
combined with these things if we look at
something even more complex you know
step one brown meat and oil until it's
brown on all sides step two you pour off
grease we actually get this wrong we
predict that the oil should leave the
mixture at this point even though the
gold says none but if you think about
grease and oil probably fairly similar
embeddings overall and so what we it's
conceivable that it could have left at
the same time then in the next step
nothing particularly interesting you
know we predict all these directly named
entities but then the interesting part
is in this step for where the line is
bring to boil then turn very low cover
simmer about one and a half hours or
until meat is tender meat should be
fairly easy to predict as an ingredient
that's being used here it's explicitly
mention of the text what's interesting
is that we actually predict all of these
other ingredients that were combined
with the meat in the previous step so
it's actually managed to figure out that
this is actually a composition of all
these entities and it predicts them all
together at the same time and to show
this effect a bit more quantitatively if
you remember how we select an update
entities we choose a set of entities we
average them and then we apply the
action function to them and then we
write the new embedding back to the
correct memory slot weighted by the
original attention on that slot so if
two entities are selected they're
embedding representations should usually
move a lot closer to each other in
embedding space because they're both
being partially overwritten by the same
vector and as it turns out if we look at
the percentage change in cosine
similarity of entity embeddings that are
being combined we can see that they're
generally
moving a lot closer to each other and
embedding space now for the skeptic
among you you can tell me that that's
obvious if you select all of them at the
same time at the first step they'll all
move a lot closer to each other in a
bedding space so we should actually look
at which ones aren't supposed to that
and it turns out if we superimpose that
graph on this one we can see that if you
just actually select entities that
aren't supposed to be combined in that
step they don't move close together at
all in embedding space you know there's
obviously a bit of noise that leaks here
and there but you know with with a good
cutoff you could probably get rid of
most of that so we're simulating entity
effects fairly nicely what about actions
well this entire model runs on the
premise that action functions are
applied to entity embeddings that induce
state changes if it works correctly we
would expect semantically similar
actions to end up having similar action
functions embeddings and that hypothesis
is true if we compare action functions
in embedding space they end up in a
fairly nice part so the cut action is
near the slice split snap splash mashing
ends up being your spreading puree and
squeezing so the internals of our models
seem to be looking at the same patterns
that we're trying to replicate and
finally our state representations have
to be useful for a downstream task you
know we have to show that our simulator
can encode an advantageous
representation of the process being
described using the world information
that we provide it to it so we applied
our state simulation model to recipe
step generation so at each step we use
the state embeddings of the entities to
see in an LS TM generator and we chain
it to generate the next step in the
recipe and across the board our model
represented here in orange does better
than competitive base lines such as seek
to seek or an attentive seek to seek and
it's consistent across metrics such as
blue Rouge as well as these metrics of
vf1 and SCF one where we pretty much
look at whether we generate the correct
action in the next sentence or the
correct state change in the next
sentence and interestingly one of the
baselines that we ran was using the
entity state embeddings from the
recurrent entity Network tracker so we
use the tracker of the recurrent any
network that baseline which is also sort
of learning this entity this
fine-grained entity representation and
we see how well the state embeddings
that it encodes do on this task and it
is worse than the NPN across all metrics
indicating that the action oriented
simulation that we're using actually
plays a role in encoding better state
representation
for downstream regeneration and a quick
example you know if we see this recipe
step generation with an ingredient such
as butter you know the first step is to
preheat the oven to 425 degrees these
neural networks immediately jumped a
pretty common answers for something our
car's preheating an oven like lately
greasing baking pan with oil or
combining all ingredients with mix in
mix well our model knows that if you
have some butter and it's raw you're
probably going to melt it which is
exactly what the references as well so
the takeaways text only gets you so far
you really need a model of the world to
do good understanding you can use you
can encode these priors into a neural
network architecture and that model the
world can be learned from data in future
work we're looking at stories we're
looking at dialogues we're looking at
scientific processes and we're also
looking at you know what type of models
of the world can we encode to do better
on these downstream tasks and luckily
for me I work in a group that makes a
lot of these models of the world between
VirB physics connotation frames and all
these other things there's a lot of data
that we have to actually create these
world models to do better in stories
dialogues and scientific processes so
we're looking at encoding those into
this pipeline thank you
since there was coffee break right after
that I guess we have some time for
questions
think that one right there Thanks
great come presentation I was just
wondering uh if because you're working
on food recipes if just because of the
nature of food that you're you're
picking up like single sense types of
words mm-hmm so when you say that when
use that word entity if you're kind of
referring luckily referring to a
particular sentence whereas if you put
this into the wild you might think
things like you know the house blew up
when he was cooking meth or salt in my
wounds great example or you know
scratching the cherry car paint job you
know
yeah so that's so the question is to
simplify down will this generalize so if
we were looking at different domains
besides just cooking well this will
something like this even work so I would
say that the simplified version of it
which we had for here with a fairly
simple model of the world where we just
had six state changes applied to 385
verbs in the cooking domain works while
you might need a much larger world to
actually simulate for another task so
that you can you can actually get
capture all of those effects and one of
the things we're working on is using you
know larger lexicon of verbs as well as
a larger set of state mappings that
those verbs can induce for tasks such as
dialogue and and stories um seems like
this is a natural for incorporating
outside ontology so you learned all this
just from reading recipes but if you
tried incorporating ontology to know
about things you haven't seen in recipe
before
what type of ontology is are you
suggesting just a you know dictionary of
what a carrot is and that you never saw
parsnip recipe but the ontologies yes so
we didn't do it in this work in future
work it's one of the things that were
looking at a lot of the lexicons we're
trying to look at as being a model of
our world are in fact ontology x' that
look at how different verbs what effects
they use so we're using a lot of frame
structures as models of our world okay
the last question so great talk so you
did not elaborate on the data set much I
was wondering so there are a lot of
these videos of cooking online or even
some of these recipes have like
intermediate like photos of different
states could you do some kind of
multimodal reasoning over this ten yeah
that was one of the goals that we were
sort of looking at for future work is
how to integrate this you know great and
expansive data source of video and
images and how we could integrate that
and we're actually working with
collaborators at Cornell right now who
are looking into that sort of stuff
pretty much how you can represent the
intermediate state using images as
opposed to maybe crowdsource labels so
we're pretty excited about the what's
going on with that work there's some
amazing new datasets and hopefully we'll
be able to do something with it
okay let's thanks the speaker Gunn
you